also wanted to point out everyone kind
of assumes that dermatologists are
experts on everything skin care which
isn't the case like we saw here
dermatologists are medical doctors their
specialty is medical skin conditions
standard Dermatology training doesn't
cover much on regular skin care products
skin care is a really broad field there
are tons of other experts involved
toxicologists chemists pharmacologists
epidemiologists biologists estheticians
even influencers who have tried tons of
products might have more relevant
expertise for a particular topic so
before you trust someone think about who
the most relevant experts are for that
topic and check whether they say the
same thing and if you're presenting
yourself as an expert it's only
responsible to check what the relevant
experts say on their topic before you
make content